non
mon enfant
deux tomes
me faire confiance
[ __ ]
dungy les mois
othman en plus
non
il dit
m
non
la tête
il
i
tous
le festival de cannes 93 au rating en
septembre s de l'info s de l'intox
charles bronson new york
à toi de jouer tu dis que c'est de
l'info toi - pourquoi moi parce que je
subis cannes ouais je crois devant lui
sur la presse là bas dans la presse de
qualité est bien placé pour le savoir
oui et toi brunson far west quand je dis
donc tu dis que c'est de l'art de la
boxe parce qu'il ya le festival de
deauville le quai très rapproché ouais
mais je peux le dire maintenant jeune
m'a dit que c'était de la faune alors on
va savoir avec vous et votre expert si
ligue 1 eh bien mon cher thierry avant
de donner la réponse je voudrais
demander à jeanne moreau de nous
accorder une petite faveur
jeanne est ce que vous accepteriez si
vous n'avez pas tous bons à toutes les
réponses de faire pour nous un petit
gages
ok oui est ce que vous pourriez nous
chanter un petit couplet d'un de vos
airs dont je suis un fan et à mon avis
je ne suis pas le seul d'accord pas
d'accord alors voici la réponse c'est de
l'intox
aux bravo il
les scores le score ça fait 1 0 pour le
cow boy à 1 0 pour le cowboy bravant la
pluie bon philippe klein commentaire à
faire là-dessus tu peux nous expliquer
oui thierry c'est de l'intox encore que
les producteurs américains et les
distributeurs de films font pression sur
les organisateurs pour que le festival
de cannes soit déplacé de mai à
septembre
mais rassurez vous j'ai eu
personnellement en ligne france where
lembach qui est le secrétaire général du
festival de cannes
il n'est plus du tout question de
déplacer le festival de mai à septembre
une fois seulement la france avait
accepté de faire plaisir c'était en 1939
pour le premier festival à la demande
pressante de nos amis allemands nous
avions dû attendre sept ans avant
d'avoir le premier festival
mais rassurez-vous c'en est fini des
pressions pour non plus dit moi je vais
vous refaire d'ici la fin de mission
peut-être alors j'aime quand vous parlez
de vos échecs dans les interviews
parlait toujours de la nuit de l'iguane
qu'est ce qui s'est passé alès qui sait
pas la leur nous avons remarqué en tous
les cas
bah oui parce que ça mais pas tellement
arrivée sous et bien très peu de
critiques dramatiques en amérique et
c'est le critique de washington post qui
est venu sans être invité qui a écrit
tout de suite le papier mais qui était
désastreux pour tout le spectacle pour
tout le monde et bien sûr moi qui joue
un rôle très important
et après quelques jours de réflexion je
lui ai envoyé un mot pour le remercier
je n'étais pas à la hauteur quoi
maintenant tout va bien sûr depuis la
rentrée veut une presse dithyrambique la
turbo sous vos trois films est ce que
l'avis de la presse vous touche
elle me touche pour le destin du film
mais au moment où je fais les choses et
même après que je les ai faites
j'ai une espèce de voix intérieures jai
un juge suprême et je sais s'il ya
quelque chose qui cloche ou s'il ya
quelque chose qui est vraiment exact
et sincère et si j'ai donné le meilleur
de moi même donc c'est important et ça
ne l'est pas et la vie des gens autour
de vous certaines personnes qui sont un
peu des juges lui ont été demandées dans
la rue et des gens ce qu'ils pensaient
en sortant d'un film qui s'appelle la
vieille qui marchait dans la mer laurent
baffie costard de stars
avez vous trouvé jungle relance humain
pareil à lui même allait toujours
sympathique
vous très bien les formidables quelle
est la scène que vous avez préféré tout
en général je peux pas te paraître
longues heures voilà est-ce que ça vous
a choqué la scène d'amour entre le moine
trappiste et l'iguane je souhaitais
beaucoup de monde et lorsque le shérif
et l'amour ou chez phadia il ya un
symbole pour vous oui bien sûr auquel
ya l'amour de l'attirance sculpteur vous
avez pleuré à la fin du film lorsque
bobby dénonce amer aux allemands
quittent émotion quelle est la meilleure
scène du film à votre avis la meilleure
bas vers le début quand un couple non tu
veux dire n'importe quoi qu'elle est on
reprend quelle est la meilleure scène du
film à votre avis si la meilleure scène
du film toy lembras quel est à votre
avis la plus belle scène du film au
début quand on voit qu'ils marchent
quand le troupeau d'éléphants rentrer
dans le sacré coeur sur la musique du
dernier et 47 ou en live de georgette
lemaire ça vous a plu cette semaine
ouais mais je trouve ce sont des
situations extrêmement improbable et
quelle est la casquette que vous avez
préféré la cascade la cascade
quand il se jette du vide mais il se
jette dans le vide ça a été un crève les
séquences la séquence c'est quand ça
dans le vers la fin quand ici avec des
boîtiers c'est un film en costumes
d'époque de pau doit dieu non mais
attendez qu est ce qu on en a compté
pour me vanter des conneries c'est beau
la peur mais il n'a pas vu aussi
alors pourquoi vous m'en parlez ce n'est
pas lui c'est insensé votre comportement
qu'est ce que je vous ai dit mais c'est
à sens et ça vraiment les gens veulent
parler de tout sans jamais rien l'avoir
vivement
les gens sont prêts à faire n'importe
quoi donc rassurez vous la prochaine
fois que vous entendrez parler d'un go
films même si c'est du bien vous le
prenez cissé du mal vous tombez vous
voyez alors vous connaissez la terre
entière et je vous faire une interview
vous dire que je vais vous citer des
noms de gens ah oui c'est terrible ça
mais pas pour vous faire chier le temps
paillade
c'est nous qui gagnons à vous écouter
alors vous citer des noms de gens et
vous réagissez par exemple louis malle
si vous l'avez beaucoup aimé vous
l'aimez toujours touchant vous croyez
que vous étiez d'abord l' ascenseur pour
l'échafaud avec les à main et les amants
à derna fidesz notre film ensuite on va
en parler mais est ce que vous auriez
fait les amants si vous m'aviez pas et
excusez-moi hameau avec lui quand même
très bien entendu tout vous l'auriez pas
fait vous l'auriez fait ça n'aurait pas
été possible sans ennui et sans moi
après vous avez fait viva maria où elle
a eu un peu des problèmes parce que peut
le dire maintenant il ya prescription
bardot quand même je vais un peu chier
quoi son nom il n'y a pas vraiment eu
l'anglais c'est vrai qu'elle était un
peu chiant mais c'est elle et qu en tout
cas par mois tout à fait bien encore oui
oui mais parce qu'il y avait tous ces
journalistes ou ses photographes autour
et ce qui comptait pour les médias
c'était la rivalité s'était alors que
rivalité il y en avait absolument pas
mais quelquefois c'était emmerdant
datant du 8 heures une chaleur de plomb
c'était pas toujours alors je lui
demandais de me prévenir quand même ça
va mais c'est difficile
non un petit lui de s'occuper plus
d'elle parce qu'avec vous il savait que
c'était réglé un peu dans q2 est
bouillonnant sion elles sont maintenant
il ne faisait parce qu'il a la santé
beaucoup plus fragiles ils la sentent
est beaucoup plus fragile
c'est vrai que quelquefois je ne prenais
pas très bien de sa part à lui orson
welles vous l'écoutez en quelle année à
g koné
je débute est presque j'ai connu à la
comédie française
ça devait être en 1951 est gelée suivi
toute sa vie de membres l'époque il a
jamais été très mince il était il était
bel homme et puis j'ai jamais pensé à sa
corpulence
après je me suis pas inquiété un petit
peu inquiété mais c'était à cause de sa
fragilité de la santé
et lorsque je me sentais malheureux mais
j'ai toujours trouvé beau c'est vrai
qu'il n'aimait pas qu'on le voit mon jeu
non il n'aimait pas savoir qu'un jour le
surpris en neuf bonnes on prend mon jeu
wii on marchande le widi un cochon de
lait entier qu'il avait devant lui avait
donné une adresse à côté de madrid et
j'y suis allé avec un ami il y avait
personne et on nous a proposé
différentes salles
une sorte d'auberge et puis j'ai ouvert
une porte et or ce n'était là j'ai vu
qu'il était furieux j'ai fait comme si
je ne l'avais pas vu et un jour vous a
proposé de tout quitter pour le suivre
aux états unis ne peut pas tout quitter
ils voulaient payer le dédit de la
comédie française
bunuel c'est un homme que j'aurais pu
aimer follement s'il avait été un peu
plus jeunes ont marqué son ménage mais
je n'ai pas mais ça ne gênait lui alors
je dis lui disais que j'aurais aimé
qu'il soit mon père et lui me disait que
j'avais tort parce qu'il aurait été
absolument kirani qui m'aurait sûrement
enfermé dans un placard
vous aurez pas le super de cinéma non ça
va pas un peu comme votre peur oui mais
mon père pour nos 13 ans alexis tenais
gallas mais c'est vrai que d'une
nouvelle vous raconter ça qui était
petit bolide qu'il était sensible mais
pas sentimental
oui c'est très sympa retrouvés et que
quand ils étaient petits pendant qu'ils
travaillent y mettait du sparadrap sur
la bouche de ce feu il est éthique aux
abords des grands à bon mais oui
et quand il était grand candy
travaillait avec jean claude carrière et
vieillit mais des du sparadrap sur la
bouche de ça ça parce qu'elle était trop
bavard bidon alors j'ai travaillé dans
nikita avec besson et vous êtes assez
fasciné par sa recherche du graal ce que
vous appelez la recherche du graal
oui oui parce qu'il est obsédé comme
tous les hommes dont nous avons parlé
mais peut être d'une façon parce qu'il
est plus jeune et qu'il appartient à
cette époque dans laquelle nous vivons
ça n'est pas détourner ni par la
littérature ni par un art plastique
c'est cinéma cinéma cinémas et quand
nous avons travaillé ensemble j'ai
tourné quoi quinze jours dans les kits à
je me suis amusé parce qu'ils
s'amusaient absolument follement hills
et refaire les scènes
tu peux me faire un peu comme ça appuie
si on essayait comme ça un peu plus
triste un peu plus des plus lent plus
rapide on sentait que ça pouvait durer
durer vous pardonner tous au réalisateur
vous appelez ça des particularités pour
pas dire de défaut oui oui il n'ya pas
il n'y a pas de défi alors je remplis
pendant un mot j'étais tellement en
extase béate qui m'est arrivé d'oublier
mon texte
c'est embêtant bah oui et puis surtout
dans le prince et hambourg avoir un trou
dans la salle
dans la cour du palais des papes c'est
mia le vent qui passe m gabin bleue
tombée avec le gamin oui mais moi j'aime
tous les hommes avec lesquels je
travaille et lino ventura peu près avec
lui oui dans le grisbi le vieux et puis
j'ai fait un film avant la suite j'ai
oublié le titre
n'oubliez non pas du tout c'est qu'il
était catcheur lino ventura oui je sais
on va avoir une histoire que quelqu'un
d'autre dont il paraît qu'il aurait été
catcheur on regarde
il est vrai faux journal la cites
bonjour en bon gros jovial il joue à
nous amuser chaque midi
et pourtant sous son aspect bon enfant
le journaliste claude villers cache bien
son jeu
mais pourquoi tant de haine claude
miller est un petit garçon gros qui
gâchaient faisait ch a été à l'école
alors sans arrêt c'était la patate la
grosse tous et un jour je me suis dit il
m'ennuie poli je vais leur casser la
gueule
et pour faire les choses à fond il est
devenu catcheur professionnel
bien sûr c'est d'arriver sur le
ruissellement sur le ring avec vous au
noir clouté la chaîne de vélo à la main
etc
c'était la grande époque du catch que
villers faisait trembler la france de
1958 à 1961 il fut l'un des quatre
frères masqué d'une troupe de catch
ambulant fait marquant il a toujours
joué le rôle du méchant mal aimé mais
pourquoi claude villers on savait ce
drame des gros a le gros c'est celui qui
retrace l'épopée vaincu ma part pas la
crème dans la figure
si c'est le caucus et le c'est touchant
voter mais pour la première fois depuis
longtemps dans un gymnase
il retrouve ses anciennes amours et
égrène ses souvenirs d'anciens
combattants toujours nativité c'est que
chéri bibi en revanche a terminé sa
carrière comme receveur des postes à
lille mais dit aussi sur les
enseignements qu'il en a tiré sa
répartie du rêve
le catch c'est pour moi c'est une
manière de raconter les histoires devant
moi j'aime bien raconter des histoires
c'est et universités à moi
journaliste puis animateur de radio les
histoires il en raconte tous les jours
depuis presque trente ans avec entre
autres le tribunal des flagrants délires
et son vrai faux journal aujourd'hui une
belle carrière qui laisse quelques
regrets à certains comme ils étaient
quelque chose
quatre heures avant d'être journaliste s
de l'info est de l'intox
jeanne moreau à l'oreille oui alors
maintenant pendant que nos amis branson
et bronson réfléchit cependant que vous
chez vous vous chercher pour savoir
c'est que l'info c'est de l'intox
nous on va se faire très plaisir on va
écouter vainement
j'ai la mémoire qui flanche j'me
souviens plus très bien comme il était
très musiciens qui jouaient beaucoup des
mères
tout d'entre nous doit commencer par un
très long baiser sur la veille le thé du
poignet un long baiser sans fin j'ai la
mémoire qui flanche j'me souviens plus
très bien
quel pouvait être son vrai nom et quel
était son nom
il s'appelait je l'appelais comment
l'appeler dedans
pourtant c'est fou ce que j'aimais
la plupart sont bons j'ai la mémoire qui
flanche j'me souviens plus très bien
de quelle couleur et c'est dieu je crois
pas qu'ils étaient bleus
était une verve ratait une grille et
cette île verte durée
au change et il a tout en couleurs pour
un nouveau oui on s'est connus on s'est
retenu on s'est perdus de vue
perdus de vue on s'est retrouvés
ou ces régions
on s'est séparés
chacun pour soi on est pris dans un
tourbillon de la vie
je remuais soit la mêlée retomber dans
mes bras elle est retombée dans mes bras
pendant ces cônes et quand on sait
revenus pourquoi se perdre de vue le
perdre de vue
quand on s'est retrouvé dans s'est
réchauffé pourquoi se séparer
alors tous deux ont les
pas pris dans le tourbillon de la vie
on a continué
la tournée tous les devants
là c'est tous les noms
alors maintenant claude miller catcheur
avant d'être journaliste s de l'info ou
de l'intox c'est à toi tu jouais le
brunson version far west à ton avis se
dit que c'est allé trop vite c'est de
l'info toi et pourquoi
et c'est à dire je joue un peu sous les
probabilités ah ah c'est le premier que
je vois père salah maintenant et toi
alors d'une chine l'inde ou vous m'avez
dit c'était de l'intox
je suis inquiet là pour moi de l'avoir
vive et pelles de la prouesse de l'intox
ma pauvre jeanne on a déjà un couplet je
crois qu'on en a deux totalement de
l'info on applaudit à bouxwiller
alors quel est le score laurent 2 1 pour
le paul bailly dont 1
philippe est ce que tu as un commentaire
à faire et oui c'est de l'info claude
villers n'a pas vraiment un physique de
patineurs artistiques
il est la preuve vivante et vivante
qu'il ne faut pas forcément coucher pour
arriver dans ce métier n'est ce pas ma
fille je ne sais pas pas pour dire mais
deux fois que vous vous trompez quand
même c'est bien de perdre de temps
est-ce que vous êtes riche je vais rien
vous avez quoi
non j'ai pas grand chose je vis avec ce
que je gagne ou sur le juin quand vous
avez vendu votre propriété du prix
vermeille sont hectares quand même c'est
bien touché de l'argent pour moi mais
jamais des dettes qui je venais de
divorcer et contrairement à ce qu'on
pense
un immense américain ça peut coûter cher
je veux rien à part pour éviter sous du
tout contraire et dans ces moments là
quand vous aviez vraiment besoin
d'argent
est ce que vous avez pensé à faire la
publicité non non j'ai fait des
émissions de radio radio monte carlo
j'ai raconté la vie des stars je
voyageais beaucoup c'était assez
étonnant d'ailleurs c'était une période
où j'avais pas un rond j'ai même pas de
quoi prendre un taxi
j'ai pas tellement longtemps ses 1,80 et
j'étais invité partout alors on faisait
un hommage à jeanne moreau à san
francisco un autre à chicago j'étais
invité à boston je voyager en première
classe gt habillé par les grands
couturiers qui prêtait des vêtements et
j'étais logé dans des dans des palaces
et heureusement que j'avais des amis ou
comme invitée à dîner mais je pouvais
sentir son de l'avion venu argent non
mais la vie est formidable parce que
j'ai trouvé sur mon chemin où des gens
sont menées à ma rencontre et je n'ai
jamais désespéré il y avait toujours
quelqu'un qui me donnait 100 francs ou
500 balles et
ça s'est toujours bien passé mais c'est
vous honneur parce que c'est pas le cas
de toutes les stars on va voir le
magazine du faux les arnaques de stars
m
c'est l'histoire d' arnaque aussi
célèbre que leurs auteurs l'histoire de
star qui pensent que plus on est riche
célèbre et plus on en veut pour
alimenter son compte en suisse
pour cela tous les moyens sont bons mais
les ethnologues vous le diront comme
dans la mafia
chaque clan a ses spécialités
hors-d'oeuvre voici le gris gris qui
rapporte avec danièle gilbert
elle avait troqué sa vraie candeur de
belle fille idéale pour devenir
marchande de bagout pharaonique au
pseudo propriété euphorisante guy lux
lui proposait ses lumières aux amateurs
du loto des chiffres permettant de
décrocher le gros lot dans un délai de
six mois
les numéros en question ont été choisis
par un ordinateur l'union départementale
des consommateurs des alpes-maritimes
n'a pas apprécié inculpation un peu de
piment maintenant avec le recel d'objets
d'art volées ces moustiques ex chanteur
de rock des années 60
reconverti dans la brocante vous ne
pouvez plus vous avez besoin d'un petit
régime ne vous adressez pas
l'illusionniste dominique webb
il n'a réussi ni à faire maigrir les
eaux du nid à hypnotiser son juge
voici maintenant les sportifs du trafic
ou plutôt les trafics des sportifs
convaincus de trafic de drogue diego
maradona s'est enfui vers son pays
l'argentine
les napolitains ne veulent plus entendre
parler de leur ancienne idole un comble
dans la capitale italienne de tous les
trafics
enfin le dessert voici les sportifs qui
passe par la case prison sans même avoir
touché un centime
comme mike tyson par exemple qui
n'aurait pas hésité à violer la
concurrente d'un concours de beauté
heureusement l'amérique qui n'est pas
rancunière la laisser sortir pour jouer
son dernier match car le public qui a
toujours adoré les stars et les voleurs
les aime encore plus quand ils sont les
deux
les arnaques de tard voilà qui vous
aurez aurait pu arriver si vous n'aviez
pas votre rigueur naturel parlez-nous de
films que vous avez tourné s'appelle
anna karamazov voulait tourner à moscou
et à les lignes grade ce que vous comme
beaucoup d'acteurs de votre génération
vous avez été tenté à un moment parle
par le communisme n'a jamais jamais
aucune guerre chinois pouvaient jamais
cru maintenant notre papa qui vous avez
donnés cette éducation qui vous avez dit
vous messier ou pas du tout pas du tout
c'est peut-être justement montées
intéressantes orateur il avait un café
c'est un à force d'entendre les
conversations de bistrot des bistrots
que non non c'est de voir un secret à
l'époque quand vous voyez je sais pas il
montand signoret qui partait en urss
ça vous tue pas vous les trouviez
ridicule vous aviez envie de leur dire
de pas y aller non non non puisque je
suis pas militante
d'ailleurs pendant très longtemps j'ai
eu un sentiment de culpabilité de ne pas
être aussi tranchée de ne pas d'avoir
des avis sur tout et puis le privilège
de l'âge c'est que maintenant je peux
dire franchement ouvertement que ninon
l'histoire devenez raison en quelque
sorte oui est ce que vous pensez
puisqu'on en parle régulièrement dans la
presse
est-ce que vous pensez que la monarchie
représente un avenir pour ces pays là
quand on voit le roi de roumanie qui
essayent de revenir le roi de bulgarie
le roi de yougoslavie
grand duc qui va à leningrad je croyais
que ça allait venir vous raccorder les
séquelles des scories qui traînent
aurait fait de jouer à la connaissance
que j'ai tout le monde sait que rien ne
recommence jamais mais je peux pas
répondre sur ses chances morguard alors
d'accord
en 1919 le traité de trianon rend son
indépendance à la slovaquie bratislava
s'affranchit de la tutelle tchèque avec
à sa tête car le trois descendants de la
dynastie d'été chaîne qui à fait fondée
au 9e siècle l'état slovaque
car le 3 reste au pouvoir jusqu'en 1938
où il est chassé de son pays par
monseigneur kiso un proche des nazis
l'héritier au trône antonin 1er net en
exil en 1951 à paris où il vit toujours
en cultivant la nostalgie de son pays
oui effectivement mon premier souhait
serait de visiter tout simplement mon
propre pays que je n'ai jamais vue
d'aller à la rencontre des gens tout
simplement un souhait comme quelqu'un
qui est expatrié qui voudraient voir de
là où il vient où sont ses racines
le projet de visite devient affaire
d'état comme à bucarest
michel de roumanie a été refoulé dès son
arrivée prague refuse d'accorder tout
visa en tout d'un premier vaclav havel
l'a encore rappelé dans une déclaration
le 2 novembre dernier le retour
d'antonin premier représente une réelle
menace pour l'unité tchécoslovaque et
une vision réaliste des faits nous amène
à penser que les sentiments
nationalistes slovaques sont développées
par d'anciens dirigeants communistes au
moscone boss le bac a aussi envie
d'exister donc d'une certaine manière
ils ont trouvé le pas parce que jacques
a trouvé dans le prince et ona une
figure emblématique qui pourrait servir
de porte drapeau finalement de cette
mémoire collective
la famille d'été chaîne incarne la
résistance slovaque toujours vivace
vis-à-vis des tchèques témoins les 14 %
de suffrages recueillis par le parti
monarchiste slovaque aux dernières
élections
même si le prince antonin n'a pas de
projet politique
oui enfin on voit maintenant
sérieusement
il est un devoir pour moi au cas où est
ce la pâte le souhaitent de les aider je
veux dire n'importe quel citoyen le
ferai tout comme alexandre de
yougoslavie ou siméon de bulgarie le
prince antonin n'est pas un pucci en
attendant l'appel de son peuple il reste
simplement d'un bain de foule parmi les
siens
nos prétendants aux pommes de feu va qui
interdit de séjour par batla babel s de
l'info s de l'intox
jeanne moreau à l'oreille oui alors
maintenant pendant que nos amis branson
et bronson réfléchit cependant que vous
chez vous vous chercher pour savoir
c'est de l'info si c'est de l'intox
nous on écoute les rembrandt très très
très bien placé sur la playlist de
double jeu
oui
mais
paul
ok ce faire
tél
m
au fait
à cholet
est-ce que vous
du
vainqueur
tout respect
zhu
on paie
une
oh
dieu
nous
eh oui
l'esprit
test
et
alors le prétendant au trône de
slovaquie interdit de séjour par vaclav
havel s de l'info est de l'intox
cette fois de jouer et charles ix et de
l'intrus toi ouais pourquoi je suis pas
un simon édition du jour l'intuition
jusqu'à présent ce n'est pas tellement
non mais tu continues tu continues et
toi ça je dis que tu dis que c'est
l'info ouais d'accord tous les trois bon
le jeanne moreau qui est quand même déjà
deux couplets nous a dit que c'était de
la pause
tous les trois pour l'info on écoute
l'expert philippe guérand écoutez jeanne
je crois qu'on s'achemine directement
vers la compilation des oeuvres de
jeanne moreau à la fin de cette émission
seulement puisque c'est totalement
totalement totalement de l'intox on
applaudit laurent
nous y croyons bah oui d'après alors
laurent quel est le score le score on
s'en fout c'est brunson qui va gagner
enfin de toute façon tu as raison le roi
pour le cobol et ça fait trois couples
et pour jeanne moreau philippe est ce
que tu as un commentaire à faire oui
thierry c'est de l'intox tout dans ce
sujet absolument tout est faux les
photos le faux prince qui entre
parenthèses est un vrai noble mais
français nous avons trouvé l'un des
seuls pays de l'est à n'avoir aucun
prétendant
la slovaquie est en effet le seul pays
de l'est à ne pas avoir été une
monarchie dans son histoire
thierry excuse moi mais ça n'est pas moi
qui ai inventé la slovaquie pour
l'applaudir
alors maintenant on peut le révéler ce
stade de l'émission votre mère était
danseuse ici jeanne aux folies bergère
j'étais venu donc quand vous étiez petit
et non pas du tout il n'était pas encore
enceinte de moi à elle a dansé ici pour
la première fois elle avait 18 ans oui
elle faisait partie de la troupe de tino
girl qui accompagne et joséphine
bancaire quand elle a débuté ici
moi je suis arrivé après j'ai interrompu
la carrière de ma mère c'était un sujet
tabou à la maison on n'en parle pas non
jamais ma mère m'en parlait plus tard
mon appareil plus tard qu'en cachette et
plus en fouillant dans les affaires dans
l'art moi j'ai trouvé une excuse de
vieilles vieille boîte est dedans il y
avait des photos sublimes de maman
danseuse et alors quand vous êtes arrivé
ici tout à l'heure vous êtes venus ici
pour la première fois c'est la première
pour la première fois je mettais les
pieds ici c'est pas mal c'était très
touchant
votre père lui était restaurateur paul
moreau il avait un restaurant à mon mari
a closed doors la wii il a avec son
frère un scène mais il a vécu c'est à
repourvoir votre succès puisqu'il est
avec vous il est épaté comprend pas il
était très fier intime au spectacle par
exemple toujours on placer au deuxième
rang ce qui me désole parce qu'il
s'endormait au bout d'un quart d'heure
mais avant de s'endormir aideront flux
comme un sonneur il prenait dans le
dirai aux ses maxis et même si puis
après de remettre et puis sera-t-il
voyez les films mais c'est dégueulasse
tu te laisse embrasser par gabin ce
vieux con il pourrait être ton père oui
c'est intéressant comme commentaire et
il était fier mais en même temps ils ne
comprenaient pas ce qui l'a réconcilié
avec moi c'est que je suis une très
bonne cuisinière voilà donc ils voyaient
que je savais faire quelque chose de mes
dix doigts dans le restaurant de votre
père vous ne travaillez pas du tout vous
vous étiez pas non c'est pas la main à
la pâte
non mais des amène une cousine la
demande terre julienne qui était une
femme épatante j'ai connu des femmes
vraiment formidable et qui avait une
auberge et je servais les pourboires
justement vous me faites un enchaînement
formidable on va regarder le bas fichaux
une histoire de vie font
qu'est-ce que volatile dame un grand
café crâne léger et 3 6 3 sur verre
d'eau ouais un verre d'eau et demi par
darty un café crème un verre d'eau à des
cas crème et bien d'autres
vous avez une ordonnance ya plus de
tartines
vous voulez une autre cote non messieurs
1 si vous voulez un goût de cake
non qu'est ce que vous allez promo bien
passé parce qu'il faut qu'on fasse des
genoux non non vous voulez que je vous
parle un petit peu non pas du tout ça va
vous en ce moment non non parce que moi
j'ai déjà des problèmes
bush et jeb un makila caprine grippe
domine grille par les clippers là et
puis je me suis inquiet que ça fait
quand même huit jours de la paix et à
l'école est finie et il est venu le
médecin il est venu et on n'était pas là
dans l'été sortie quand il est bon
il informe et émana oui parce qu'on
avait une soirée avec des copains dans
une boîte échangiste météo forniquent
club et des soirées lundi vous
connaissez bien
alors vous vous êtes mariés
la première fois c'est en 49 avec jean
richard que changer son nom parce que ça
ressemblait à jean richard hein et vous
est retrouvée enceinte est en fait le
mariage a eu lieu la veille de
l'accouchement
un samedi c'est gratuit c'était juste un
an ouais c'était juste avant ce qui fait
que le photographe il était obligé de
redescendre et l'escalier on m'avait
prêté un grand manteau et je dire n'ont
pas traité manière mais madame la tête
seulement si vous n'aviez pas été
ensemble vous seriez marier quand même
non c'est frambois vous avez un enfant
jérôme qui a 42 ans aujourd'hui
vous le voyez souvent je le vois en ce
moment à peu près une fois par an oui il
vit en californie
si vous dites j'ai eu un enfant mais je
n'ai jamais été meurt c'est dur à dire
famille non pas du tout je suis maire ce
que j'ai dit je m'étais maman poule 1
terminée en internement pernel dans le
sens conventionnel
ensuite vous avez une liaison super
secret avec pierre cardin
oui et puis vous vous êtes mariés pour
la deuxième fois avec leurs réalisations
pas un vrai amour avec card à sa durée
combien de fois où ça en dirait plus
quatre ans et puis après vous être marié
ou donc avec le réalisateur de
l'exorciste et de french connection
william friedkin dit vous êtes mariés
parce que vous a touché qui vous demande
en mariage
c'est la première fois qu'on vous
demandait en mariage vous avez des en
fait oui alors ce divorce était quelque
chose de tout vente à vous parler de
deux années noires
le fait que j'ai accepté je lui accorder
une valeur un peu sa crème et
j'ai souffert de cette disproportion
entre mon désir et la réalité
non pas que je me sentais responsable et
non pas que je le trouvais lui
responsable mais ça a été une douleur
très violente et très profondes pensées
vous a coûté de l'argent en plus c'est
pas grave c'est pas grave on ne vous
n'étiez pas très au courant des
banquiers des avocats tout ça ou vous
n'avez pas voulu être au courant non
c'est pas grave c'était surtout la
déchirure clé quand vous dites je ne
pense pas dans ma vie avoir ému un homme
à avoir à non c'est pas grave du tout un
bon et je le reconnais je veille à la
plupart des gens sont comme moi on est
amoureux on est passionnément attaché on
repousse violemment mais l'amour
l'alliance ce que j'appelle l'alliance
est à dire un échange profond à des
intéressés un amour absolu
je n'ai pas connu en tout cas moi je
n'ai pas connu oui quelque part j'espère
le connaître avant de mourir et
peut-être que ce ne sera pas sous la
forme que tout le monde que tu imaginer
maintenant on va voir un sujet car n
avoir pas vous changer les idées s'est
consacré à la guerre
en janvier 1993 lorsque douvres sera
relié à calais par le tunnel sous la
manche l'angleterre ne sera plus tout à
fait une île la manche qui a toujours
préservé le royaume uni des invasions ne
pourra plus alors jouer son rôle de
rempart naturel contre l'ennemi le
secret défense est maintenant levé et le
times du 11 novembre dernier révèle que
le tunnel peut être inondée en cas de
conflit au moment de la signature du
traité
j'en ai moins en a eu vent d'une
préparatifs qui se faisaient pour la
défense nationale anglaise qui a demandé
le changement au plan du tunnel mais
nous ne savions pas quoi exactement
persan voulait ni des as été un secret
nous avons insisté auprès des des gens à
londres des ministres en ce moment et de
défense sans rien moins jusqu'à
récemment quand je pense le gouvernement
venait à bout nous quand on met un peu
les inquiétudes du public anglaise de
qu'est-ce qui se passerait au qu'un oeil
à l'invasion
est-ce quelque chose de sérieux était
prévu sur ordre du premier ministre
britannique
löw pourra s'engouffrer dans le tunnel
grâce à une série de conduire relié au
fond de la mer en quelques heures la
partie centrale du tunnel sera inondé
soit treize des 37 km inve sous la
manche et selon le times et le 20
janvier 1986 le jour de la signature du
traité sur le tunnel ferroviaire que le
principe d'un dispositif de sécurité fut
adopté une destruction par l'armé
nucléaire et en définitive tom quinn
ministre de la défense de l'époque
préféra le système d'innovation qui
permet une remise en état ultérieure du
tunnel mais le tunnel at il une réelle
importance stratégique pour le
gouvernement britannique il est très
important de neutraliser le tunnel parce
que c'est le meilleur moyen d'une
occupation terrestre
aujourd'hui certes on fait d'abord la
guerre avec l'aviation avec les missiles
mais il s'agit ensuite de concrétiser la
victoire par une conquête terrestre est
donc coupée le tunnel c'est freiner une
invasion mais rappelez-vous ce
stratagème a déjà été utilisé dans
l'histoire alors me y serait-il entrer
dans les services sur ta britannique
les tunnels sous la manche une honda
blanca de guerre s de l'info est ce
donateur jeanne moreau alors ouais ouais
alors maintenant pendant que vous
chercher chez vous pour savoir si c'est
de l'info ou si c'est de l'intox
cependant vous allez chercher une bière
dans le frigo nous on va regarder
quelqu'un dont on a vu le pis
arthur ashe ya quelques semaines
aujourd'hui c'est la balade qu'il a fait
pour sa fille il dit à jacques higelin
peut-être ce qui m'a
tirant toi tirs
et rien que l'autre mère sans deux mois
sans deux mois on m'attendait les gens
caché derrière
pas
départ des siens
rien de tout ce qu'ils m'ont pied en toi
en toi
mais plus doux que le grain
de ta peau de ta voix
dans la magie pr demment cieux
manceaux sont les scores jusqu'aux
portes
du ciel ou
tout tout viens-tu ou m'attendre
merveille
et
en amont sol
berger pas
flo des sorts qui la longe et des rêves
étoilés
sous le grand maman
et peut-être ce qui me re ly à toualy à
toi
et d'autres que ce corps
dans le soir dont deux choix
que tu es en rouleaux tout tu
pour l'empêcher de courir
ce serait
et si tout ce que j'adore en toi dort en
moi je veux que tu le rêve veille en moi
veille pour toi
que de la terre
ouais
et puis
de nos caresses
metz handball a
vers 6h20 la quotidien le tunnel sous la
manche inondable en cas de guerre s de
l'info s de l'intox c'est à charles de
jouer à ton avis cuisine c'est de
l'intox
tu dis que c'est de l'intox tout a été
calculé depuis longtemps ouais et toi ça
alors je peux le dire maintenant
jeanne m'a dit que c'était de l'intox a
on va voir si vous avez chanté toute la
chanson où seulement trois couplets
philippe jeanne je crois que vous faites
une quinzaine d'émissions avec nous vous
allez très très forte à ce jeu là
puisque vous avez gagné bravo l'épée de
l'intox
je vais être obligé de s'exécuter jeanne
vous chanter la chanson voulaient elles
sont toutes bien j'aime ton odeur ta
saveurs les ont crus c'est pas volé on a
les cheveux longs mais je t'ai dans la
peau mais je t'ai dans la peau les os je
ne suis pas joli joli
nous ne sommes pas bo bobo mais contre
toi moi je grille
tu me fout le feu à la peau tu as
peut-être pas des bras d'athlètes tu as
peut-être pas le torse velu
mais j'adore retenir est chaque fois tu
dis que tu m'as d'impôt lit on dans ce
rapport
une bonne d'entretenir aussi très bonne
mémoire
alors laurent quel est le score final à
la surprise générale c'est charles
bronson qui a gagné le cowboy trois
points à 1
je prends ton petit téléviseur
tu va regarder tous les cadeaux qui
défilent et tu vas me dire celui que tu
veux
le mini téléviseurs philips à cristaux
liquides multistandard penser qu'anne 69
programme mémorisable merci bravo
d'harmonie alors pour toi
l'intégrale de 37 dur ma vie tu vas
continuer la nuit tout à fait bien on
applaudit aussi alors je fais
psychanalyse est à un moment de votre
vie
mais est-ce que vous êtes confessé dans
votre travail quand j'étais petit
nous avons gardé un bon souvenir pas
terrible aïe aïe aïe je crains pour moi
alors
ah bah maintenant je suis plus grande ça
va être intéressant bon ben on y va
alors atteint les confesseurs janot
et
quand vous étiez petit vous avez
réellement voulu être religieuse oui je
devais avoir 5 ans j'étais frappé par le
rituel égalité d'humeur
c'est à dire que dans la vie à la maison
c'était plutôt en dents de scie j'aimais
la musique j'aimais l'ordonance voilà
j'aime beaucoup la rigueur quand vous
dites j'ai un maître intérieur de qui
s'agit-il
jeudi à partir du moment où on n'est pas
perméable comme une éponge et où on ne
se laisse pas influencer par tout ce qui
nous entoure et qu'on ne vit pas que par
rapport au regard des autres au jugement
des autres cette voie là s'expriment
vous avez toujours préféré le terme
sensualité et sexualité écoute un peu
l'anti sexualité au fond - dont on parle
et non parce que je laisse ça aux
rapports des corps et une dimension
une dimension divine j'ai trop de
respect pour tout individu tout être
humain
à commencer par moi pour considérer que
le corps est un morceau de viande est
quelque chose qui qui se défait qui qui
pourrit et le rapport et la jouissance
le rapport d'essence et la jouissance
donne une idée plus précise de l'extase
qu simplement un orgasme 1 coûte que
comme disait mon analyste qui laisse pas
grand chose
je lui dis nous sommes autre chose que
de la mouture wii brouillon dieu le
terme croire est un terme profane ça a à
voir avec la crédulité je ne crois que
ce que je vois
j'ai une sensation très exact de quelque
chose de deux magnifiques croyons l'âme
l'esprit mais quand vous dites on vit
seul et au mur seules la solitude n'est
pas une erreur épouvantable c'est c'est
quelque chose d'exaltant parce que la
solitude ne veut pas dire être isolé ne
veut pas dire être séparés des autres
c'est être avec les autres et si je suis
conscient de ma solitude je peux encore
mieux comprendre celle des autres et la
souffrance de ceux qui ne la supporte
pas bien merci mme merkel
ce
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
antenne 2 et philips l'inventeur du
compact disc vous ont présenté double
jeu à la semaine prochaine